نستنى الان عوده نسائي افغانستان لمزاوله
العمل في مجال الصحه في المنظمات
الانسانيه منح بارقه امل باستعاده المراه
لجزء من حقوقها المسلوبه في افغانستان لكن
الطالبان وضعت ضوابط حتى في منح هذه
الموافقه فاعتبرت اولا انها موافقه مؤقتا
وحذرت ايضا من ان اعمال المراه ستكون
محدوده وهو ما يزيد من حاله الاحباط التي
تعيشها النساء بعد سلبهن حقهن في التعليم
الجامعي والعمل وقبلها حقهن في التنزه
وارتياد المكتبه والنوادي الرياضيه لكن
عوده نشاط بعض المنظمات حتى وان كان
محدودا سيخففه ازمه الانسانيه التي تفاقمت
بعد قرار تعليق المنظمات غير الحكوميه
لعملياتها احتجاجا على حضر طالبان عمل
النسائي فيها بحسب مسؤولين وتعمل حوالي
1260 منظمه غير حكوميه في البلاد وفق
وزاره الاقتصاد وتوظف الاف النساء في
مناصب اساسيه سواء في برامج المعونه
الغذائيه او في مجالات الصحه والتعليم
وتقدم المنظمات غير الحكوميه مساعدات
الاساسيه في افغانستان والتي يعاني اكثر
من نصف سكانها من انعدام الامن الغذائي
الحال